Peter King joins us now from the mm QB
how you been Peter I've been great rich
and rich you've had many bold takes in
your life it's not one of them that it's
not one of them that's not a hot chick
no not at all
well I mean you go to Vegas right now in
bet on any other team right if I asked
you yes go to Vegas right now no matter
what the odds
forget forget anything and just say you
pick one team to win the AFC West right
now who would it be
oh yeah well I mean it would be them but
you'd have to look at the Chiefs and say
they've got three in a row at home in
December in Arrowhead I mean that's a
big wet kiss from the schedule makers
right I suppose so how did they do at
home against the Buffalo Bills and
against the Pittsburgh Steelers I mean
so what is it what is it what is the
sense of why this has happened to the
Chiefs I think it's one of the really
great and interesting stories in a long
time in the NFL this is more than just
this is more than just the decline of
one aspect of this team Kareem Hunt has
gone from Gale Sayers to don Nottingham
III you know what what in the world
happened to Kareem hunt and I'm sure
that I echo nine million fantasy
football owners of Kareem on in the
United States of America right now but I
think it's not just it's not just the
fact that that they're not an explosive
offense anymore it's that their running
game is not good enough but I will make
this point and I think Travis Kelce said
it well at the Meadowlands nine days ago
when he was asked what the heck is wrong
with your team and I hate to be I hate
to go all Andy binoy you know a great
Cosell on you but I think a lot of it
has to do with the fact that teams have
understood that they're not going to be
afraid to throw the ball deep so they're
playing a lot of very conservative cover
to and they're saying listen
you're not going to throw the ball over
our head you know and you're not going
to beat us with Tyreke he'll you know on
on 50-yard go routes down the field I
think it is I think the lazy way of
looking at this is to say Alex Smith
every November in December he just you
know comes down to earth and he can't
play when the weather's bad and blah
blah blah it isn't that it's that I
think teams basically are saying to them
you're not going to beat us deep anymore
you're not going to send people up the
seam over our heads you want to beat us
in front of us that's fine but you're
not beating us with big plays anymore
Peter King of the mmq be joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so which team do
you think comes out of the NFC now that
we've got five games to go is it a
simple huncles I think the NFC is so fun
it is I think rich here's the thing
about the Eagles right now if I am Doug
Peterson I absolutely totally love this
schedule okay because here we are were
ten and one but even Doug Peterson when
he has his staff meetings with with
Frank Reich and Jim Schwartz if they're
being honest they're saying hey you know
what do we have a signature win is it
the five point Thursday night win at
Carolina that you know could almost was
a coin flip game we could have lost that
game the other nine wins all are against
teams that have losing records right now
so we need a challenge we need to see
how good we are because the one thing
you don't want to have happen especially
after a bye week you don't want to get
to football on January 13th or 14th and
say we really have no idea how good we
are because everybody we play is the
Chicago Bears they don't get a first
down for 31 minutes and I'm exaggerating
no I know but but but the point I guess
I would make about this team is they're
going to Seattle and regardless of how
everybody now views see
wounded animal not good enough all that
other stuff since they lost Richard
Sherman and kam chancellor
in those two games they've allowed 180
and 279 yards on defense and I'm not
saying they're the same defense all I'm
saying is that they have played very
well on defense without two essential
players so that's going to be a
challenge to win in the Pacific
Northwest Sunday night a hundred and ten
decibel level for three hours so that's
that's a challenge and then the
following week you got a tougher game
you stay on the west coast you practice
in Anaheim at the field of of your most
famous season ticket-holder Mike Trout
which is by the way what they're going
to do they're practicing in the stadium
in Anaheim all next week
and I just gave Rich Eisen and his
producer a great idea hey we're going to
go on location we're gonna go do the
show from Anaheim and we're gonna get 15
Eagles on isn't that exciting and we're
the rich Eisen show is on KLA a home of
your Los Angeles Angels you know oh well
hey there's a lot of little backs to be
scratched right there but light bulb
moment Peter then you've got the Rams
and to me that's a very possible preview
of the NFC Championship game and and I
would I would only just say this about
that game which might be a lot more
interesting than people think because as
we sit here right now Rams 8 and 3 and
Philadelphia 10 and 1 now is it
impossible to think that the Eagles
could go to Seattle and lose No
and so just imagine if Philadelphia at
the Rams everybody's talking about you
heard what Mike Tomlin said to Tony
Dungy the other day that this isn't just
about this game against the Patriots is
not just about a great game it might be
for home-field throughout the playoffs
you know that's what he strongly implied
in that interview with Dungy
well I mean don't look now but there
could be at the very least a first round
by hanging on that rams Eagles game
because hey we don't want to forget
Minnesota and you know Minnesota sitting
there at nine and two so and and they
could and and all these teams in the
South they could have something to say
about it too but I think that Rams
Eagles game as much as everybody's
talking about the Steelers in the
Patriots now and and I love that game
too that Rams Eagles game is potentially
just Omega make a game it is it is and
as you point out interestingly enough
the the last Los Angeles Rams home
before their current one was in that
Stadium you know that's been
reconfigured as a beautiful ballpark
down there for Mike Trout it's
interesting storylines for that the
couple minutes I have left with you
Peter King let's some quick hitters
Aaron Rodgers coming back this year yes
or no what do you think I think he's
gonna come back in week 15 and they left
three games to try to pull a rabbit out
of his hat and to get the Packers to
have a prayer to be the second wild-card
team okay Dallas Cowboys they go over
Zeke is Jason Garrett's job on the line
you think only I think I think you have
to see how the last five weeks goes
nobody can say if they're embarrassing
five weeks in a row this is a gut
feeling have no earthly idea whether it
has a prayer but I think if Jon Gruden
really wants to go back and the Cowboys
absolutely are terrible down the stretch
and lose their last six or seven
whatever it is Jerry Jones could look at
Jon Gruden that's but but again no
insight information absolute gift so who
what are the names you hearing is being
surprised coaching hires or in the case
of Gruden reappearances with five weeks
I don't I'm not sure it's gonna be a
very weird year I don't think David Shaw
goes to the NFL yet I think maybe two or
three years from now he may I think
you're going to round up a lot of the
usual suspects there isn't
a real hot name in college football say
like David Shaw or Chris Peterson I
think Chris Peterson probably if he came
if he went to the NFL would really want
to stay West and I think it's probably
josh mcdaniels matt patricia and jim
schwartz and and round up the usual
suspects interesting and then you know
I'm sure you heard Chuck Pagano his
press conference yesterday that we're
gonna play later on in this edition of
this show where he recreated the Sonny &
Cher song moment waking up odd the I got
you babe moment from from Groundhog Day
it sure sounds like he's a guy that's
that's that knows his fate is gonna hit
him who else do you think knows their
fates can hit him we're sitting here
Peter I mean look I think it's I think
if I'm Jimmy Haslam as much as people in
Cleveland will faint at this I think
it's important that he keeps Hugh
Jackson he still has the respect to that
locker room and nobody's winning with
that team right now
I don't think there's going to be as
many changes as you think I want to hear
from Bruce Arians about whether he wants
to continue I think he does so whether
they would make a decision on Aryans I
doubt it I think he comes back and I
think there will be some questions to be
asked in Tampa Bay
I don't think Tampa Bay wants to start
to be known as this franchise Schiano
lasted two years
lovie smith lasted two years they don't
want to be in this in this revolving
door thing I think unless they play
horrible down the stretch that Dirk
cutter stays and I think the other big
question is going to be the Giants Ben
McAdoo does he stay or does he go my gut
feeling is that he'll go but only John
Mara knows that right now you think your
socks get Giancarlo Stanton what do you
think now no I think it would be a dumb
a dumb idea stadium I mean you're gonna
you better watch out behind a monster
Peter but here's the point rich you know
right now they have pillaged
the farm system and you tell me how
close they are right now
I don't think they're that close I think
that one of the reasons they're they're
a good team right now but not a great
team is that they've held on to a lot of
these young guys and you know where
would they be without mookie betts they
might trade Jackie Bradley but where
they'd be without mookie betts Xander
Bogaerts is a staple I don't I'm not a
big fan of just using your farm system
to go get eighty million dollar guys or
whatever state and how much does he make
thirty I don't know what but we got too
many of those guys let's let's have a
few more guys who are 21 years old and
who were promising all right Peter you
got it let's chat soon always love our
conversations thanks a million
that's Peter King the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience